i'm gonna go after the biggest heresy in
the adventist
church and it is something called the
investigative
judgment that was a clip from alan
parr's video
entitled i was wrong wrong wrong about
seventh day adventism
part one in which he called the
investigative judgment
the biggest heresy in the seventh-day
adventist church
i'm gonna be responding to alan parr's
accusation
in this video i'm gonna be talking about
the investigative judgment
along with a couple of other claims he
made in his video
and i will also be exploring scripture
to see whether or not the bible supports
the doctrine
of the investigative judgment now just
to be clear
i am a seventh-day adventist and alan
parr
identifies himself as a
non-denominational christian
but this video is not about proving
whose denomination
is right it's about proving what the
bible teaches
because ultimately it doesn't matter
what i believe
or what alan parr believes or what our
churches believe
it matters what the bible says but
before we get into our subject
i want to thank hide it in your heart
for sponsoring this video
hide it in your heart is a christian
youtube channel
which makes animated scripture songs to
help you memorize god's word
and give you a closer walk with jesus
some of the scripture songs that you can
watch
on hide it in your hearts channel
include
fear god and give glory to him which is
based on revelation chapter 14
verses 6 through 7 ask seek
and knock which is based on matthew
chapter 7 verse 7
and seek ye first which is based on
matthew chapter 6
verse 33. by the way hide it in your
hearts
videos are suitable for all ages not
only adults
but children as well since the videos
are animated
children associate them with cartoons
and it's a good way to help your
children memorize scripture
in fact my daughter laura's favorite
song from hide it in your heart's
channel
is fear god and give glory to him click
on the card in the upper right hand
corner of the screen or the link
in the video description to subscribe to
hide it in your heart
on youtube and check out some of their
videos today
now i'm going to play a clip from alan
parr's video as he talks about the
investigative judgment
and then i will respond to it what is
this investigative judgment
it is the idea that jesus christ
is in the heavenly sanctuary in the most
holy place
and he is investigating the lives of
every single believer
and he's going through all of your sins
and he's going through all of the things
that you've done wrong
and he's investigating it he's
investigating it
to one day make a judgment about whether
you
are going to be in heaven or hell that's
why it's called the investigative
judgment he is currently in heaven at
this time
looking at everything that you're doing
are you obeying the sabbath are you
looking at pornography
are you lusting are you lying are you
stealing are you for are you forgiving
people
are you coveting people are you jealous
he's investigating every detail of your
life
and then he's going to make a judgment
and he's going to
judge whether you are fit to be in
heaven or hell my friend
that is a perversion of the gospel
that is a perversion of the work
of christ on the cross that is an insult
to the atonement
of jesus christ is that really a
perversion of the gospel
alan mentioned that jesus is in the most
holy place
investigating the lives of all believers
right now
jesus entered the most holy place of the
heavenly sanctuary
in 1844 i talked about that in my last
video response
to alan parr where i explained to the
2300 day prophecy
in daniel chapter 8 verse 14 and jesus's
high priestly ministry
in the heavenly sanctuary if you want to
get brought up to date about that
click on the card in the upper right
hand corner of the screen to watch that
video
before continuing but just to summarize
a little bit
daniel chapter 8 verse 14 says for 2
300 days then the sanctuary shall be
cleansed
this 2 300 day period
prophetically symbolizes 2 300 years
which came to an end in 1844 and the
cleansing of the sanctuary was performed
on the day of atonement the reason it
was necessary is because the sins of
all penitent israelites had been
transferred there
throughout the daily service so on the
day of atonement
the high priest entered into the most
holy place
and performed a ceremony to cleanse the
sanctuary
of their sins leviticus chapter 16
verses 15-16
talks about this stating then he shall
kill the goat of the sin offering
which is for the people bring its blood
inside the veil
do with that blood as he did with the
blood of the bull
and sprinkle it on the mercy seat and
before the mercy seat
the mercy seat was in the most holy
place so he shall make atonement for the
holy place
because of the uncleanness of the
children of israel
and because of their transgressions for
all their sins
and so he shall do for the tabernacle of
meeting
which remains among them in the midst of
their uncleanness
the sanctuary and its services symbolize
the work
christ is doing for us in heaven as our
high priest
in the heavenly sanctuary just like the
sins of penitent israelites were
transferred
to the most holy place through the daily
service
a record of our sins are transferred to
heaven
and written in the judgment books these
books will be reviewed in god's
judgment before the second coming of
jesus to determine
whether or not we will be worthy of
heaven
because they will reveal whether or not
we are truly converted
the fact that a phase of god's judgment
takes place
before jesus second coming is
illustrated in revelation chapter 14
verses 6 through 7 which states then i
saw another angel flying in the midst of
heaven
having the everlasting gospel to preach
to those who dwell
on the earth to every nation tribe
tongue
and people saying with a loud voice fear
god
and give glory to him for the hour
of his judgment has come and worship him
who made heaven and earth the sea and
springs of water
notice part of this end time preaching
of the gospel
is the message that the hour of god's
judgment
has come that means it's taking place at
the same time
the gospel is being preached to the
world before the second coming of jesus
daniel chapter 7 verses 9 through 14
gives us
insight into the workings of this
pre-advent judgment
stating i watched till thrones were put
in place
and the ancient of days was seated his
garment was white as snow
and the hair of his head was like pure
wool
his throne was a fiery flame its wheels
a burning fire a fiery stream issued and
came forth from before him
a thousand thousands ministered to him
ten thousand times ten thousand stood
before him
the court was seated and the books were
opened
so here we have a picture of the
commencement of god's heavenly judgment
and the next two verses verses 11
through 12
are significant because they identify
the timing of this judgment they read
i watched then because of the sound of
the pompous words
which the horn was speaking i watched
till the beast was slain and its body
destroyed
and given to the burning flame as for
the rest of the beasts
they had their dominion taken away yet
their lives
were prolonged for a season and a time
this judgment starts while the horn
which is a symbol for the antichrist
is speaking pompous words this is before
the second coming of jesus
because when jesus returns he will
destroy the antichrist
and during this phase of the judgment
the lives of professed christians
are investigated to determine
whether or not they will be allowed into
heaven the bible indicates that god's
judgment begins with the church first
peter chapter 4 verse 17
says for the time has come for judgment
to begin
at the house of god and if it begins
with us first
what will be the end of those who do not
obey the gospel of god
and what we are judged by is our works
addressing the corinthian church the
apostle paul wrote in 2 corinthians
chapter 5 verse 10
for we must all appear before the
judgment seat of christ
that each one may receive the things
done in the body
according to what he has done whether
good
or bad and to be more specific the
standard of this judgment
is based on god's law of 10 commandments
james chapter 2 verses 10-12 says
for whosoever shall keep the whole law
and yet stumble
in one point he is guilty of all for he
who said
do not commit adultery also said do not
murder
now if you do not commit adultery but
you do
murder you have become a transgressor of
the law
so speak and so do as those who will be
judged by the law of liberty it's
obvious that the law it's talking about
here
is the ten commandments because it
quotes two of the ten commandments
which is do not commit adultery and do
not murder
and the reason why the ten commandments
are the standard in god's judgment
is because they determine whether or not
we have
genuine saving faith james chapter 2
verse 17
says thus also faith by itself
if it does not have works is dead
another way of saying
dead is incomplete so if someone claims
to have been saved by faith
but their works don't correspond to
their confession
their faith is incomplete that's not
true genuine saving faith
that's presumption james chapter 2 verse
says you believe that there is one god
you do well
even the demons believe and tremble
demons know god exists but their works
are evil
so if your faith in god consists of a
mere acknowledgement of his existence
but is not accompanied by good works
your salvation is no more secure
than the demons and we all know where
they're going
in matthew chapter 25 verse 41
jesus said that eternal fire is prepared
for the devil and his angels not
everyone who claims to be a christian
will make it into heaven
because they have not been truly
converted and their works
attest to that jesus said in matthew
chapter 7 verses 21-23
not everyone who says to me lord lord
shall enter the kingdom of heaven
but he who does the will of my father in
heaven
many will say to me in that day lord
lord
have we not prophesied in your name cast
out demons
in your name and done many wonders in
your name
and then i will declare to them i never
knew you
depart from me you who practice
lawlessness
and one more thing before i respond to
the next clip by alan parr
the reason for the investigative
pre-advent judgment
is not so that god will know who is
truly saved
and who is truly lost he already knows
that nothing surprises god
so the reason for this judgment is so
that onlooking beings like god's
heavenly angels
will know who is truly saved and who is
truly lost
god's heavenly angels minister to god
for our salvation
and also pay attention to what's going
on in this world
in connection to the plan of salvation
the apostle paul wrote in first
corinthians chapter four verse nine
for i think that god has displayed us
the apostles
last as men condemned to death for we
have been made a spectacle to the world
both to angels and to men also
after the saved make it to heaven they
may have some questions
as to why some of their family friends
or favorite ministers are not in heaven
with them
and then god will give them an
opportunity to look over his books of
judgment
and see why they will see that those who
lost
out on eternal life had some sins that
they did not repent from
or some secret sins in their lives that
others were not aware of
that kept them out of heaven after god's
judgment is complete
satan will be held accountable for all
of the sins that jesus atoned for
this is illustrated by the scapegoat in
leviticus chapter 16.
i'm not going to read it because it's
mentioned throughout the chapter
and it's kind of long but i'll give you
a quick summary
as part of the ceremony of the cleansing
of the sanctuary on the day of atonement
the high priest presented a scapegoat
before the lord
the high priest would then lay his hands
on the head of the scapegoat
and confess over it the sins of the
children of
israel putting them on the head of the
goat
and then the goat would be sent away
into the wilderness
this would cleanse the earthly sanctuary
and what the symbolizes
in terms of the heavenly sanctuary is
the sins of the saved
that jesus atoned for being transferred
to
satan in conclusion of the investigative
judgment
which cleanses the heavenly sanctuary
let's move on to the next clip of alan
parr
because clearly the bible teaches
that our sins past present and future
are already paid for
clearly somebody hasn't been reading
their bible because that's not what the
bible teaches
speaking of jesus romans chapter 3 verse
25 says
whom god set forth as a propitiation
by his blood through faith to
demonstrate his righteousness
because in his forbearance god had
passed
over the sins that were previously
committed
it's our past sins that god forgives
once we repent from them and confess
them to him
the bible nowhere says that our present
and future sins are forgiven
as well that's just wishful thinking
another verse in confirmation of this
is second peter chapter 1 verse 9 which
says
or he who lacks these things is
short-sighted
even to blindness and has forgotten
that he was cleansed from his old sins
again it's our old sins we are cleansed
from
not our present and future sins as well
not to mention that's a teaching of the
once saved always saved
doctrine which alan parr believes and
that's why he said that
next clip the bible teaches that when
jesus got on the cross
he said it is finished all right let me
i'm getting ahead of myself here
let me just read some scripture for you
all right let me read some scripture
the bible says this in hebrews 10 but
this man jesus
after he had offered one sacrifice for
sins
forever sat down on the right hand of
god
from henceforth expecting till his
enemies be made his footstool
by one for by one offering he had
perfected
forever them that are sanctified
whenever you're finished with something
what do you do you sit down
right the bible says that christ sat
down at the right hand of the father and
he's
making intercession for you and i it
doesn't teach that
jesus is up in heaven somewhere writing
down and identifying everything that you
and i do right or wrong
making a judgment and investigating the
details of our lives that
is not the bible that's not the the
atonement right
that's not what the bible says when
jesus said it is finished
he was talking about his atoning
sacrifice he didn't mean that there
wouldn't be a judgment for the church
and i don't think it's jesus
specifically who records our sins in
god's judgment books
the bible seems to indicate that it's
the heavenly angels that do that
for example malachi chapter 3 verse 16
says
then those who feared the lord spoke to
one another and the lord listened
and heard them so a book of remembrance
was written
before him for those who fear the lord
and who meditate on his name notice
the book of remembrance is written
before the lord it's not
written by the lord so the lord doesn't
personally
record the affairs of our lives in his
judgment books
he has other heavenly agencies do that
and jesus said in matthew chapter 18
verse 10
take heed that you do not despise one of
these little ones
for i say to you that in heaven their
angels
always see the face of my father who is
in heaven
why do their angels always see the face
of the father
because angels intercede between us
and god so it's most likely that the
angels record our deeds in god's
judgment books
not jesus personally let's see what
other biblical insights alan parr has to
share with us
notice the bible also says this there is
therefore now no condemnation
to those who are in christ jesus who
walk
not after the flesh but after the spirit
answer me this question how can god be
investigating every detail of your life
and there also at the same time be no
condemnation on your life for those who
are in christ jesus
how can the bible say that there's no
condemnation on your life
but yet there very well might be because
right now god's investigating everything
that you're doing
yeah god's investigating everything
you're doing
to see whether or not you're actually in
christ
jesus and walking after the spirit
remember
if there's no condemnation for those who
are in christ
jesus and walking in the spirit that
means that there
is condemnation for those who are not in
christ to jesus
and not walking in the spirit and the
investigative judgment
will determine who that is that's the
purpose of the investigative judgment
it's not to make those who have truly
accepted jesus
fear that they could lose their
salvation at any moment
it's to weed out the true from the false
converts
next clip you see this is the problem
with the advent this is the biggest
foundational problem is that there's no
certainty in salvation with them
that's why they have to obey the sabbath
that's why they have to eat certain
things that's why they have to
do all this stuff because they believe
that christ is in heaven and he's
currently investigating all of their
lives
and their salvation is not really secure
and so as a result
you know what i can't really be certain
about my salvation
so therefore i've got to do all these
things it's a works based
faith it's a workspace salvation which
is why
you need to steer clear of this wrong
as long as you abide in christ as long
as you stay
in a relationship with jesus you have an
assurance of salvation
first john chapter 5 verses 11 through
13 tells us
and this is the testimony that god has
given us
eternal life and this life is in his son
he who has the son has life he who does
not have the son of god
does not have life these things i have
written to you
who believe in the name of the son of
god
that you may know that you have eternal
life
and that you may continue to believe in
the name of the son of god
notice this indicates salvation is
conditional
upon having a relationship with jesus
and continuing
to believe in him therefore if you
abandon the christian faith
you will be lost but as long as you
remain in the faith
you have an assurance of salvation and
adventists don't follow the bible
in order to secure our salvation we
follow the bible because we
are saved and we demonstrate our
appreciation
for god's gift of salvation and our love
for jesus
by our willing obedience jesus said in
john chapter 14 verse 15
if you love me keep my commandments
so uh let's keep going john 19
30 jesus said on the cross it is
finished
right they can they suggest that it's
still going on in heaven that he's still
making this
investigative judgment notice how allen
twisted that around to make it sound
like jesus
was talking about the judgment when he
said it is finished
like i said before jesus was talking
about his atoning
sacrifice not the heavenly judgment
scores of bible verses attest to the
fact that there is still a work of
judgment
to be completed in heaven for example
ecclesiastes chapter 12
verses 13-14 says fear god and keep his
commandments
for this is the whole duty of man for
god shall bring
every work into judgment with every
secret thing
whether it be good or whether it be evil
the bible says that our sins are
forgiven and forgotten
hebrews chapter 8 verse 12. that means
that god will no longer hold
our sins against us once we repent from
them and confess them to him
it doesn't mean that a record of our
sins isn't preserved
in the judgment books of heaven that's
another issue
ellen g white in the great controversy
says this through the grace of god
and their own diligent effort
they must be conquerors in the battle
with evil
do you see that through the grace of god
and their own diligent effort
they must be conquerors in the battle
with evil
do you see what she did she combined
the grace of god and your own diligent
effort
and if you have both of those then you
can be conquerors then you can get into
heaven then you can be saved
wow talk about trying to make ellen
white say something that
she didn't actually say she simply said
god's grace in combination with our
efforts
will ensure us victory over sin she said
nothing about trying to earn salvation
by our works
and what she said is nothing new you can
find verses in support of her statement
all throughout the bible
let me give you a couple of examples
titus chapter 2
verses 11 through 12 says for the grace
of god that brings salvation
has appeared to all men teaching us that
denying ungodliness and worldly lusts
we should live soberly righteously and
godly
in the present age denying ungodliness
and worldly lusts takes effort james
chapter 4 verse 7 tells us
therefore submit to god resist the devil
and he will flee from you resisting the
devil and submitting yourself to god
takes effort god's grace empowers us to
overcome sinful living
but don't expect to gain the victory
over sin without any effort on your part
it doesn't work that way let's continue
the difference between christianity
and any other world religion is that we
believe
that salvation is by grace through faith
alone
no works every other religion believes
that you have to work
or do something in order to get to
heaven and this
my friend is what the adventist church
is teaching
under the surface when you peel back all
of these different
layers all right that's such a strong
man argument
the adventist church believes in
salvation
by grace through faith but alan parr is
making it seem like it teaches salvation
by works
by misinterpreting ellen white quotes
you know
one of the biggest mistakes right there
is going to the writings of ellen white
to criticize what we believe because we
don't consider ellen white's writings
a source of doctrine we consider the
bible as our source of doctrine
and if you want to know what the
official doctrines of the seventh-day
adventist church are
just visit adventist.org hover your
cursor
over beliefs and click on fundamental
beliefs
that will take you to a page which
explains the 28 fundamental beliefs
which are the official doctrines of the
seventh-day adventist church
and fundamental belief number 10
entitled
the experience of salvation states
in infinite love and mercy god made
christ
who knew no sin to be sin for us
so that in him we might be made the
righteousness of god
led by the holy spirit we sense our need
acknowledge
our sinfulness repent of our
transgressions
and exercise faith in jesus as savior
and lord substitute and example
this saving faith comes through the
divine power of the word
and is the gift of god's grace in other
words
salvation is by grace through faith and
it is a gift of god
just like ephesians chapter 2 verses 8
through 9 says
for by grace you have been saved through
faith and that not of yourselves
it is the gift of god not of works lest
anyone should boast
if you've been inspired by what i've
been sharing with you in this video
and you would like to learn more then i
highly recommend that you download
the free christian app by amazing facts
the amazing facts app includes sermons
bible studies answers to difficult bible
questions
a christian blog and more click on the
link in the video description to
download the amazing facts app
on ios or android today
the investigative judgment is a biblical
doctrine
the book of revelation tells us the hour
of his judgment
has come the bible says that judgment
begins at the house of god
and the standard of god's judgment is
his law
of ten commandments an investigation of
the lives
of professed christians is being
performed
in heaven right now to distinguish
between true and false converts and
those who are truly saved
will be taken to heaven at jesus's
second coming
this video is part of a series in
response to alan parr's criticism
of the seventh-day adventist church i've
made other videos responding to false
claims
that alan has made about the sabbath
ellen white
and william miller click on the screen
to check out my playlist
including those videos don't forget to
subscribe and click the bell
if you're new so you don't miss any of
my future uploads
thank you for watching and god bless you